covered and I think we all know and
understand this represented a
significant shock to the system and it's
ongoing impact together with Associated
backlogs coupled with extraordinary
levels of other illnesses this winter is
creating pressure that is truly
unprecedented and I want to just give
some more detail to illustrate all of
that firstly in on covet
in the final week of 2022 at the ons
estimated that one in every 25 people in
Scotland had covered now vaccines and
treatments thankfully have very
significantly reduced the health harm of
covet but even so more than 400 people
with that virus were admitted to
hospital just last week in total there
are right now more than 1200 patients
with covid in our hospitals and for
context that is double the number four
weeks ago now even if and this is
absolutely the case not all of them are
in hospital directly or solely because
of covid nevertheless the fact that they
have covered means that enhanced
infection control procedures have to be
in place and that has an impact on
Hospital capacity
in addition to the ongoing impact of
covid the NHS is of course dealing with
backlogs of treatment built up in
earlier stages of the pandemic now it's
important to see that progress is being
made here for example over the Autumn
more than 90 percent of operations were
performed as planned and the number of
operations was a third higher than 12
months previously so that's good
progress but the impact of backlogs
remains significant
in addition to covet the country has
been experiencing extraordinary levels
of winter flu more than a thousand
patients were admitted to hospital with
flu during each of the last two weeks
and finally there has also been a rising
number of cases of strepi and other
respiratory viruses resulting in a
significant demand for services so the
impact of this combination of covert flu
and strepi is clear in the statistics
measuring demand for Health Services if
we look at the two four day Christmas
and New Year holiday periods NHS 24
answered almost 100
000 calls that's the highest number in
more than a decade in the final week of
last year compared to the week before
calls to NHS 24 increased by around 50
percent
the impact on the ambulance service has
also been significant compounded by a
longer turnaround times which I'll come
back to later but the ambulance service
responded to more than 16
000 emergency incidents in the past week
which is 11 higher than the average over
the last four week period And I want to
stress at this point though the massive
contribution that both NHS 24 and the
ambulance service through new and
innovative ways of working are making to
preventing pressure on hospitals being
even greater than it already is